[Music]
thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to check
out their scientific thinking course and
get 20 off an annual premium
subscription
so
[Music]
[Music]
you've heard some worm horror stories
right we were looking some up just for
this episode and came across a recent
headline from rs technica that read
army of warm larva hatch from man's bum
visibly slither under his skin
and if that's not enough to terrify you
and make you feel very uncomfortable
there's always the stories of painful
stomach cramps or diarrhea or nausea
that eventually turns out to be caused
by some worms that have taken up
residence inside someone's intestines
it is terrifying and wild to think of
something so much smaller than us
causing so much havoc so
as we watch the cilia lining a worm's
gut beat its own soothing pattern
wouldn't it feel like
almost a little bit of justice if this
site wasn't so peaceful like what if
worms had to worry about their own guts
being taken over by a parasite
if you found yourself in this position
seeking some schadenfreude over a worm
we have some good news for you
the worm you see in the middle of this
tank is currently hosting this strange
fellow called a radiophyra
james our master of microscopes had been
on the hunt for the radio fire after
seeing this
two radio fires linked together in a
chain as one divided to make more copies
of itself it had come from the inside of
one of the worms that he'd been watching
when he'd accidentally squeezed a worm a
bit too hard under the cover slip and
caused the ciliate to pop out
radiophyra belonged to a general group
of ciliates called aztomes or as tomatid
ciliates we've talked about ciliates a
lot on our channel which means that if
you've been watching for a while you may
have picked up on the fact that from
time to time we have said that most
sleets have an oral groove that opening
lined with cilia that sweep bacteria and
algae and other tiny bits of food into
the organism we've seen that oral groove
at work and ciliates like stenters and
paramecium functioning as the ciliate
equivalent of a mouth but as we have
always said most ciliates you will have
inferred that this does not mean all
ciliates and if you are looking for an
exception to the rule as tomes are that
exception as tormented sileous are
diverse but they are unified by one
shared feature or rather they are
unified by their lack of one shared
feature a mouth
and they do not need a mouth because
they have something even better they
have worms
[Music]
as tormented ciliates do parasitize
animals other than worms some live
inside mollusks others inside leeches or
even in amphibians but they are most
commonly associated with the guts of
annelid worms
so when james found his radiophyra he
decided to see if he could find more of
them in the other worms that were in his
samples and that meant that our master
of microscopes had to become a master of
worm surgery dissecting them so that he
could draw out the ciliates living
within
inside this particular aquatic worm were
these tormented ciliates from a distance
they also look like worms
but as you get closer
and closer their shape becomes more
definite except for you know the massive
amounts of fluff around them a dense
cloud of cilia beating away
unfortunately there is not a lot of
research on this ciliate in fact there
isn't a lot of research on astomated
ciliates in general they just aren't
destructive enough or common enough to
have become either a necessary or
convenient research subject in fact it's
not even clear whether or not we should
call them parasites
modern day papers will sometimes refer
to them as endosymbionts instead
because we don't know a lot about
whether as tomated ciliates are doing
much to their worm hosts bad or good
but the worm gut does plenty for the
astomated ciliate at one point in time
the ancestors of the associates did have
mouths but as they found their way into
worms and specifically their guts those
oral grooves became less necessary
instead the ciliates could rely on a
form of feeding called osmotrophy where
they simply absorb nutrients from their
surroundings through osmosis instead of
taking in larger bits of food through
their mouths and breaking it down
themselves as tometid ciliates could
just take advantage of the worm's
digestive system to do all of that
breaking down for them as the worms
digestive enzymes break down complex
molecules into simpler forms that can
travel through their own intestinal
walls some of those nutrients would just
go to feed the aztoma did ciliate
instead
these ciliates will actually sometimes
be picky about making sure they're in a
particular spot within their host's
intestinal tract and once they've found
the right spot the ciliates will hold
themselves in place with organelles that
range in shape some use hooks others
spines maybe even suckers
the flat shape of the ciliates helps
them stay pressed to the epithelium of
the intestines so while these ciliates
may not need a mouth anymore they have
found other traits necessary to their
survival
as tomated ciliates are found in hosts
from all sorts of environments some live
in soil some live in ponds some even
live in ocean waters and scientists are
using the general tools available now to
try and piece together how host and
endosymbiont have shaped each other and
we can see some of that intertwined
story in the ciliates mouthlessness but
the specifics of that evolutionary
change are laid out in their dna
as are the more hidden parts of that
shared history
now we cannot know whether the worms
have any feelings about their guts being
home to another organism they likely do
not have much choice in the matter but
they also likely are not prone to
emotions like resentment and the way
that we might resent a worm parasitizing
our bodies
but if they were to have feelings on the
matter we want to offer this one last
detail about aztomated ciliates many of
them have their own endosymbionts as
well bacteria that live inside them with
perhaps their own history tangled up
with their ciliate host's story as well
now we couldn't find those bacteria in
our parasitic friends but we like the
idea that somewhere out there are these
nesting dolls of endosymbionts an
organism that is an organism but an
organism that is also a home
buried within other homes
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring this episode brilliant
features hands-on interactive courses in
science engineering computer science and
math and brilliant has recently upped
the interactivity of their courses in
their scientific thinking course you'll
dive into the world of scientific
principles by exploring the laws of
physics and principles of engineering
along the way you'll gain the
understanding and insight needed to
start looking at the world in a
different way the courses are designed
for people of all levels so you can jump
in at any point and work your way to
mastery and brilliant courses are also
available offline using their ios and
android app so if you're traveling or
have a spotty internet connection you'll
still be able to keep learning if you're
interested in learning more you can get
20 off an annual premium subscription at
brilliant.org
microcosmos
the folks on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons this world of
ours just doesn't stop being interesting
there's always something else
ready to blow my mind and i'm so glad
that we can continue on our journey to
find and share those things and the
people here they are the reason that we
can do that so thank you all so much to
all of you and if you're interested in
joining them you can check out
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you